wir versuchen
Gleichberechtigung an vielen Stellen
gleichzeitig und das völlig zu Recht
umzusetzen erleben aber dass so eine
rechtsradikale Partei wie die AFD jetzt
bei 30 Prozent steht wie hängt das
zusammen das eine befördert nicht das
andere nichtsdestotrotz finde ich sollte
man gemächlichen Schrittes vorangehen
bei all diesen Änderungen und versuchen
so viele Menschen wie möglich auf diesem
Weg mitzunehmen und jetzt radikal an
Astrid Lindgren Rand zu gehen und
Takatukaland umzubenennen das ist glaube
ich alles wenig hilfreich ich glaube
schon dass Menschen verstehen was der
Hintergrund dieser dieser Idee ist aber
ich glaube man muss das alles etwas
langsamer angehen und tatsächlich finde
ich es auch befremdlich wenn ich jetzt
an jedes Wort innen hängen muss das
erleben Sie auch nur in Deutschland so
das gibt es in England nicht das gibt es
in den Niederlanden und in Italien nicht